a linked list is a common data structure
used in software development it is also
a frequent topic in technical coding
interviews in this course alvin will
explain linked lists and prepare you to
use them both in interviews and coding
projects
hey programmers alvin from structure
here welcome to our course on linked
lists what i want to do is really get
you well prepped for those link list
problems on your technical interviews so
consider this a little bit of a crash
course like i do in all of our data
structure and algorithm courses i want
to go through two pieces of information
for every single problem that is i want
to really draw things out visualize
things and understand the theory behind
a problem before i go ahead and
implement the code behind it right so
we're gonna do a one-two punch for every
single problem here so this is going to
be an introductory course on linked
lists so i'm gonna assume you know
nothing about linked lists but you're
not a total beginner to programming
right so you understand things like
while loops for loops if statements and
all that jazz i'm also going to assume
that you know a little bit of recursion
because i'm going to show you some
recursive solutions for many of our
linked list problems
and so without further ado let's jump
right in
so what i want to do is start by
understanding what a linked list is at a
high level bird's eye view the first
thing we'll need to know is that a link
list is a type of data structure right
so we're organized as data and in
particular a linked list is made up of
many nodes so as our first checkpoint
here we need to first understand what a
node is you can think of a node as just
a container for some data so when we
conceptually visualize nodes we really
think of them as some circles that i can
put some data inside here i'll put a
letter or character inside of my node
but of course you can store any data you
like it could be strings numbers
booleans or even other objects right and
i'm saying that a linked list contains
many nodes so let's say i had a bunch of
nodes they can all contain different
pieces of data so i have the characters
a b c d stored in different nodes over
here
and if i wanted to make these nodes
comprise a linked list then what i need
to do is add some links in other words
if i have a node like a i can make it
point to the next node in the data set
that is a points to b
right i can also say that b points to c
and c points to d right and the term we
actually like to use for this is really
saying that a's next is b right it's
going to be very common linked list
terminology and a pattern we're
definitely going to see in the code
later on and now you can already see why
you call this data structure a linked
list right have a bunch of nodes linked
together an important thing to note here
is about the last node d right d is the
last node in our linked list and so
under the hood we can really represent
it being the last node by it having its
next pointer pointing to nothing or more
programmatically you can have its next
set to null right the null pointer and
whatever your language of choices
so sometimes during this course i'm
going to explicitly choose to draw out
the null node or the null reference just
so we can build some very robust code
all right now that we know what a linked
list looks like i want to introduce some
other terminology that you're going to
hear right so when we refer to the very
very first node of a linked list that is
the anode in this diagram i consider
that the head it's a very common term in
a similar way we can refer to the very
last node in a linked list as the tail
right so if you hear those words in
problems we're referring to the first
node and the very last node respectively
right
if you think about it because i have
this sense of different nodes and you
know a first node and a second node we
can think of a linked list as an ordered
data structure in other words if i
started at the head of the linked list i
can just look at this node's next
pointer and i can go to the b node so i
can just move to the right
and once i'm at the b node i can see
that b has an x that goes to the c node
and the c node goes to the d node and
the d node goes to the null node which
must mean that i'm at the end of the
linked list that's a very very key
characteristic about a linked list right
a nice property to leverage about a
linked list is that it's an inherently
ordered data structure right if you want
to refer to like the positions of these
nodes and we do that programmer thing of
starting at zero i can see that the head
has a position of zero b has a position
of one and then we just go sequentially
throughout right so there are four nodes
within this linked list i can see that
the position of the head is zero and the
position of the tail is three
and so so far we're probably not seeing
the full value of a linked list like
when would this data structure have some
real utility over other data structures
that we know about in other words you're
probably wondering how a linked list
compares to an array because an array is
also an ordered data structure so let's
do that comparison right now
so here i have my linked list up top if
i wanted to represent you know a similar
data structure but in an array form it
would look something like this right i
have an array in memory and i know that
that array has some indices right so
there's a really clear analogy here i
know that the indices of an array
correspond to the positions of the nodes
of a linked list
right and obviously my link list is made
of many nodes
whereas my array
has many elements
the most important difference between an
array and a linked list is that an array
must be stored contiguously in memory
that means all of your elements in an
array are going to be stored like right
next to each other in your computer's
memory and that has a lot of
consequences in the run time of
different operations across your array
right so let's say right now i wanted to
step through a scenario let's say i have
the goal
of inserting a new element q at index 2
of my array and the key specification
here is i want to insert q at position
2. i don't wanna overwrite the current
element at position two right so at the
start of this operation i have four
elements in my array a b c d after i do
my insertion of q i should have five
elements in my array and they should go
a b q c d right because i'm inserting
some new element at index two
so how would this algorithm run at a
high level in an array well typically
all you need to do is obviously find the
index two which is right here and i know
that this is where i need to put the new
q element but i can't just overwrite
this value of c because i want to do an
insertion not an overwrite and so what
happens under the hood in your
programming language when you perform
this insertion operation well we hope
that there's still some empty space in
the array and it should occur after d
right
assuming that there's still space in
this array i would need to shift all of
the elements to the right over by one
index
in other words i need to put d to the
right i need to put c over one position
to the right and now i have perfect room
to add this q
at index two
right and of course now d would be
occupying a new index of four logically
but the important step we took here was
to actually insert somewhere in the
middle of an array that could mean that
you need to shift over a bunch of
different elements in your array right
so in this very small example i only had
to move over two elements of c and d but
let's say you had a very long array and
there were i don't know a thousand
elements after your insertion index you
would have to shift all of them over one
by one and that is a relatively costly
and slow operation for such a simple
move of inserting q right so we say that
when we insert into an array that does
have an o of n insertion time right in
the worst case if you insert at index 0
of an array that is you're inserting a
very first new element you would have to
shift everything over by one index in
the array and since there are n elements
in the array you're doing n different
shifts
awesome now let's compare that to a
similar insertion operation for our
linked list so let's say i still wanted
to insert the value of q at position 2
of my linked list well that means i need
to create a new node in memory and
what's great about a linked list is it
is not required that the nodes are
contiguous in memory in other words we
can have these like nodes exist anywhere
in the space of our computer's memory
addressing
and that's kind of a very low level
statement but the consequence of this is
i don't need to do any shifting when i
perform this insertion in other words
how does that work well if i want q to
become position 2 of my linked list now
that i've created a new q node i just
need to adjust b's next pointer
so i'm going to look at node b and reset
its next pointer to point at q
then i set q's next pointer to point at
c
and with those small changes i've
actually changed the logical order of
nodes within my linked list it would now
be this
right q occupies position two c occupies
position three and so on and what's
really great about this is let's say
that there were many nodes after my
insertion position let's say there were
a thousand nodes but i wouldn't have to
actually modify all a thousand nodes
that came after my insertion point i
just need to change about two pointers
every single time and because that's a
constant number of operations i will say
that a link less insertion if we write
it correctly will be constant o of one
time so here we see a very tangible
difference between our linked list data
structure and our array data structure
and there are many more different pros
and cons between these two but for now
we'll leave it at that and we can chat
more about them as we go throughout the
course i'm sure it's going to come up
but what i want to do for now is talk
about the core core core a linked list
algorithm and that's just traversing
through a linked list in other words how
can we just touch and process every node
within a linked list
well the important thing to know is if
you wanted to like give a linked list to
someone or in other words
programmatically pass a linked list into
a function you really only need to pass
a reference to the head node of a linked
list because if i give you the headnode
of a linked list
by accessing the next property of every
node you could have access to the full
sequential list right and so to actually
implement a traversal algorithm on a
linked list we just need a handful of
variables most importantly we need like
a current variable a current reference
to look at the current node of the
linked list we're iterating through
right so if i have this current node of
a and i want it to go to the next node i
can just look at current.next or
something similar in the programming
language of your choice and i can just
set current equal to current.next then i
would be at the b node
and b also has a next so i do that again
at the c node i can just keep continuing
this process right assigning current
equal to current.next
until at some point once i'm at roughly
the tail
current would be d and so current.next
would be this null node or this null
reference and if i set current equal to
next i'll be right at null and that can
be a perfect condition i can catch
in other words we can stop the algorithm
when current is equal to null we know
that at that point would have visited
every node of the linked list
so as i went through this high level
trace i was kind of speaking upon this
algorithm as if it was an iterative
solution and i'll also show you how you
can solve this one recursively it's
really the same line of thinking at this
point i would want to actually hop into
some code so we can see the nuts and
bolts implementation of a linked list as
well as the core traversal algorithm
through a linked list all right let's do
this so here i am in my text editor i'm
going to be doing this in javascript
although you should be able to follow
along in your language of choice so the
first thing i want to do is just
manually build a linked list and to
start i'm going to need to create a node
class right so we're going to stay a
little bit object-oriented here
just create a node class so for me in
javascript i need to give it a
constructor
and in terms of the properties we're
going to need to store inside of an
instance of node i only need two things
i need to store the actual value but i
also need to store a reference to the
next node in the linked list if there
even is a next node right so to my
constructor i'm just going to take in
the value so i can say this.val equals
val
and i'm just going to always initialize
my next to be
null
right i can just manually reassign this
next property
and if you have this class written
that's all you need to start creating
some linked lists albeit manually so
let's say i want to construct a linked
list i'll just create a few instances of
node so i can create node a make it a
new node i need to pass in the value to
be constructed i'll just give it some
characters here maybe some capital
letters this time so the character a
i'll create a bunch of nodes like this
and so i'll have my b my c and my d
i'll give them some corresponding values
naturally i'm storing strings or
characters within the values of my
linked list but you can make them you
know numbers if you want it's no big
deal
what i want to do now is actually link
these nodes together that way i can just
have a link list i can start writing a
few algorithms on right so typically
this part would be kind of taking care
for you already if you're on an
interview you can assume that you're
taking in a properly structured linked
list but if i want to just like test
some code for myself what i can do is
say things like a's next is going to be
equal to the b node right so i'm making
a's next property
now become
the b reference so i'm actually linking
these two nodes together right a's next
is pointing to b the same way b's next
is pointing to c
c is next is pointing to d
and there is no other nodes in my linked
list i'm going to leave d alone
because i know automatically d's next
would currently be pointing to null
which does represent the tail of my link
list so like visually i think of this
sort of structure i have a is my head
that points to b
which points to c
which points to d and technically d
points to like null so i'll be explicit
here and just draw that one out
nice so now that i have my
linked list ready to go
let's go ahead and write our traversal
algorithm on it that is i just want to
iterate through every node of the linked
list and maybe just print out the value
something very very foundational here
and so i'll maybe choose to make this
its own function i think that would be
the best way to go about doing this
so i'll create a nice function here i'll
call it just print
linked
list and it's going to take in the head
of all ink lists and i'm going to stay
kind of abstract here and i just like to
call it head
right
there's my nice empty function and in
terms of how i would actually want to
call
this function the client would have to
call print linkedlist and give it like
the real head of the linked list which
for me in my little example here is just
a reference to the a node
cool so i'm actually receiving the head
node which is an instance of node as
of the head of my linked list here
and so let's go ahead and now set up our
algorithm so we're going to really just
implement the algorithm we just traced
out on the whiteboard so if i want to
just traverse through a link list and
print out every node i'm going to need
to continually update a current pointer
so i'll say current equal to
the head of the linked list which means
i'm really starting at the very
beginning of my linked list
and then from there how far do i need to
go well you want to keep running this
algorithm while
your current pointer is not equal
to null right because if current is not
equal to null then there's some stuff to
still iterate through
now we get into the meat of the
algorithm if i wanted to like print out
or process my current node i'll just
console.log here i'm going to print out
this current node's
value
right and notice that i'm writing all
this logic in terms of current because i
hope to update current properly at the
end of every iteration right so now that
i printed out current's val what i want
to do is update what current is pointing
to
so what i should do is set current equal
to current.next and don't be fooled here
this is a very simple variable
assignment
all right so let's run this code and
then i promise that i'll trace through
how this actually operates it's very
short code but really the foundation of
most linked list algorithms so let's
give that a run over here i hope to
print out my characters abcd awesome and
there i have them so how does this code
work well let's try to update and
annotate this drawing as we step through
the exact code here right
so i know that in the context of my
function over here i'm really only going
to track a really important variable of
current and that starts at the head of
my linked list which is passed in as the
a node so technically give myself some
room here i would say that the current
variable starts
by referencing
the a node so i'll kind of represent
like that it's aligned horizontally
right
cool and what i want to do now is
consider my condition so my condition is
checking all right while this current
variable is not equal to null then run
the code inside of the while loop so if
i check that on the first iteration that
condition is true right current is not
equal to null so i can run the code
inside which means i just print out the
value of the current node right since
current is an instance of node when i do
console.current.val i would be printing
out the a that was initialized inside of
it so that gives me my first iteration
now here's the important part
right now i know that current is a so in
this moment that means current.next
would be actually referring to the b
node
so if i set the current
equal to current.next it has the effect
of literally
moving this over to the b node
now i can check my condition again is
current not equal to null that's true so
i print out my current value of b
and then go to the next at this point
the process just continues right the c
node is still not equal to null so i
print it out over here and go to the
next note of d
now this is still true right
d is not equal to the null and so i
print out d
and i actually precede another iteration
right so right now current is d
current.next is null so this would
literally happen i set my current
equal to null but things work out great
here because when i check this condition
i'm going to check
is current not equal to null in other
words is null not equal to null and
that's false so i exit my while loop
right and that's how i'm able to print
out every node of my link list right
abcd
so i think something to draw your
attention to right now is how we write
this condition
i think the best way and the most robust
way to write this code is to check
uh while current is not equal to null
the most common mistake i see people
make is
they know like generally that your
condition should be about like roughly
the tail of your linked list and so they
might try to say well current.next is
not equal to null right but that would
actually cut your iteration short if i
ran that i would only really print out
abc
right because when i'm at the d node
right i would be checking all right
before i even print out d
what's d's next well d's next is null so
i won't even print out d which is bad
right so generally when you try to write
your algorithms especially about linked
lists try to write it as like present as
possible right so i'm not going to do
any premature checking of the next node
unless i really really have to instead
it's better to actually go to the next
node and then exit when you actually are
at the null pointer right the null node
so let me return this back to its former
glory
and we'll just make sure that this still
works this is our classic implementation
of a linked list traversal it's going to
be the baseline code for almost all of
your linked list algorithms let's take
this a step further and i'll show you
how you could write this same logic but
recursively it's really the same logic
you just turn it into a recursive call
and a base case right so let's go ahead
and do this one together as well
then i promise in the
next section i'll give you a nice
problem to work through
and so if i want to frame this one
recursively what do i need to do well i
like to start with my base case your
base case should basically be an analogy
for like the condition you wrote inside
of your while loop in other words when
are you done with the algorithm
well i'm done with the algorithm once
i'm looking at null right so i'm going
to say if head
equals null then i'm done so just return
notice that here i'm keeping this
argument named as head because i think
of a linked list as containing
many linked lists in other words a is
the head of this linked list but if i
look at the sub list inside b is ahead
of its own linked list as well right and
c is the head of a smaller linked list
still
so i think that's okay terminology to
use for a recursive function it really
shows that you're buying into the
recursive nature here right
awesome
so i'm going to stop running and just
return out
once my head is looking at null so
that'd be once i'm at this point right
but in the recursive case what i want to
do is actually process this node so if
my
head is
not equal to null right now then i'm
over here right what i should do is just
print out
this node's value
right just like i did before
i'm just reframing current as head
and if i want to actually progress to
the next node like i did in my iterative
solution i just do a very proper
recursive call here so i'm going to call
the same function actually makes it
recursive and what should i specify as
this argument well i just want to give
the next node in the linked list right
so i'm passing in
head dot next
all right and that would be all i need
to do for this one very very short into
the point so let's run this recursive
function then i'll help you trace
through it a little bit more awesome so
it's working
the trace looks almost the same but i
think it's good if we do it side by side
with the code over here
and really the key argument we need to
you know trace through is the head over
here
so on our top level call we're really
passing in the a node as head
and so i check my base case here
is head equal to null that's false so i
go into this console.log which means i
print out the value a awesome and now i
make a recursive call upon the next node
in the linked list so if head is a then
head dot next refers to b
and since i'm making a call to that next
node in this next stack frame head is b
and i check the condition again is b
equal to null that's false so i just
print out b
over here and then make another
recursive call on b's next which is c
all right and this process continues
all the way down to let's say when head
is d right i check now this condition is
d
equal to null that's false so i go ahead
and print out d which is like the last
logical node in my linked list
and i would make another recursive call
upon d's next right so if head is d head
next is null and i would indeed make
this call
and now i'm back inside of this new call
and i check is head equal to null and
that's definitely true right now so i
return that's my base case and i end my
recursion right this base case is really
really important so i want you to
compare and contrast
these two pieces of code they really
implement the same algorithm and as we
go through these linked list problems
sometimes i'll show you both ways to
solve it depending on you know what
style of problem you're solving you
might find the recursive or the
iterative a little easier to write over
the other which is why i think it's
important to practice both but maybe you
know choose a favorite and decide what
you're most comfortable with but that
being said practice both all right let's
head back into the whiteboard hey
programmers alvin here right now i want
to go over a approach for this linked
list values problem
so hop right in right here in this
problem you're going to be given the
head node of a linked list we want to do
is return an array containing all of the
values within the nodes of that linked
list we should do it in order
bear in mind in this problem we're given
a singly linked list which means that
every node has a pointer to the next
node not in the linked list we know that
the last note of the linked list i would
have a next pointer that points to null
that being said how we can go about
solving this one well those problems
we're just going to have to force you to
implement a really core linked list
pattern that is just traversing through
a linked list in order
and so we'll start by attacking this one
maybe with an iterative description so
let's say we started from ground zero
right so we want to create our values
array and to the side we can just
initialize values to be an empty
collection and to implement this core
pattern of just traversing through a
linked list we're going to need a
variable or just a pointer and we're
going to start at the head of the linked
list right bear in mind that our
function only takes in the head but i
know the head is like the ultimate
starting point of the linked list and
eventually i could access everything
throughout the entire list so i'm going
to set my current equal to the head and
what i can do off the bat is just check
current's value and add it to my running
collection
so i have the a value inside of values
now and since i have access to the
current node i know that if i access its
next property i would have access to the
next node of b so what i can do is set
current equal to current.next basically
just moving my pointer to the next node
like this
same thing as before i can add my
current value
into the collection
i'll just proceed in this way right same
thing for c
set current equal to current next
and things get interesting once we
approach the tail of this link list so
i'm currently at the d node and i go
ahead and add that value into my values
list
what we'll have to do now is consider
the scenario when it's appropriate to
actually stop our traversal
well bear in mind that d's next actually
points to null so maybe i'll draw that
explicitly just for this drawing so d's
next is just pointing to null which
means if i continue this algorithm in
the general sense so i set current equal
to current next that means my current
pointer now points to null and i think
that would be a perfect uh stopping
condition right so once current is null
we know that we've hit the end of our
linked list and so we're totally done
and if you look at the order of our
values it is indeed the correct order
right
what can we say about the complexity of
this algorithm well if we say that n is
just the number of nodes in this linked
list then the time complexity is going
to be o of n right because we're just
are really iterating through every node
once and our space complexity if we
consider the output array that would
just be also linear in the number of
nodes over here
so i'll tell you what this looks like a
pretty good strategy we can go ahead and
implement we'll implement it in two ways
first i'll show you the iterative
version and also show you how to
implement this one recursively really
both the iterative and the recursive
code use the same sort of mechanisms
so i'll see you in the walkthrough video
hey programmers alan here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this linked list values problem so
we'll jump right in and we'll start by
implementing i think the iterative
version that we spoke about in the
approach video so if you haven't watched
the approach video definitely make sure
you check that out first right
and so i'll get the ball rolling over
here
what i want to do is use a pointer
really just a variable for me right so
i'll say let current i'm going to
initialize it to be the head
and i know that the most important
pattern i probably need for linked list
is just to traverse an order through a
linked list
and the way that looks is i want to keep
iterating while my current
is not equal to null right so just not
equal to null
null would mean the very very end of my
linked list
nice and very standard code i need
inside is to progress to the next node
of the linked list so i set current
equal to current dot next
so now i'll think about actually
generating the return type
for this function i do want to return an
array of all the values so i should
initialize that up top i'll say let's or
maybe const values goes an empty array
and then as i actually iterate through
all of my nodes of the linked list at
the tippy top of this while loop i can
just take
my current node's value
right every node has a dot val and also
a dot next so i'll take the current
node's value and just push it into
values right so values.push
that single val
and once this while loop is done running
i must have hit the end of the linked
list so i can just return the complete
values array
so before we run it one thing i want to
always emphasize is for your linked list
a main logic it's always important that
you try to write your
logic about just your current node so
for example my condition is saying while
current is not equal to null it doesn't
say like while current.next is not equal
to null right you can probably get away
with finessing code like that but it
ends up being more clunky than anything
in other words whenever i try to write
uh my logic for linked lists i always
try to stay very present right so just
worry about your current node so what i
don't like to see is patterns like this
right
current.next.val and try to just shift
your frame of reference because if you
do that then you're actually kind of
assuming that your linked list has a
particular length so instead i always
try to write all of my expressions about
simply current right so while current is
not equal to null then i push
current.val and then i can just update
current to be current.next and i can be
assured that every node is going to be
processed in this algorithm
so let's give this a test run now
and if all is well we can transition
into the recursive version now awesome
so how can we do this recursively i'll
just do that down below so the way i
would structure this one just so i get
the most optimal
complexity is really with two functions
so my main function will do almost the
same thing it is going to call a helper
function i'll call this helper function
maybe fill values and this function is
going to actually do the recursion so
it's going to take in the head of the
linked list and also a reference to the
values array so recall that in
javascript if i pass any non-primitive
types so basically things like arrays
and objects they are going to be passed
by reference right so what i want this
fill values function to do is to
actually mutate the values array because
this main function is going to return it
so what does that recursive function
look like
so we'll say fill values it's going to
take in the head and also the values
array
i'll start with the base case here and
really what we're trying to do is just
translate
the same patterns from the iterative
code just into their recursive
variations right
and so i know i need to stop my
recursion once my head is
no right so i'm going to check if
head is equal to null then you can stop
so just simply return right really
important distinction here is you're
going to have a tough time and probably
end up with some clunky code if you say
if head dot next is null right so again
i always try to stay very present in all
of my code so don't worry about your
next note just handle yourself right
eventually every node will get served
here
so if head is null then nothing much to
do just return and you can stop your
recursion
otherwise i know that head is not null
so it must be a node and i need to take
that node's value and add it to values
right so i can say
head.val and i want to push that into
the values
collection right recall that values is
referring to this
outer array here
but beyond that besides this current
head there could be other nodes right in
the remainder of the linked list so i
can just call recursively fill values
and instead of pass along head again i
need to pass along head dot next right
and that means in that recursive call
kind of jump back around and now head is
referring to the next node and so on and
then its value is going to be added all
the way until we get to the very very
last node
technically after d we would hop to
d's next which is null in which case we
would exit due to this base case exactly
and before we run it just a few issues
that i need to fix i see that i'm
missing an equal sign here and also when
i call field values of course i need to
pass along the same values array because
i know that every call wants to add its
value into the same
values array there so i'll give this a
test run
see what we get
cool and now you also know how to
implement this algorithm recursively
so the reason i like to split up my
recursive version for this algorithm
into two functions is so my recursion
doesn't actually have to create like
multiple arrays right instead
all of these recursive calls are just
adding their values to a single array
if i actually created like copies of
arrays all the way through the recursion
i would end up with like an n squared a
sort of runtime
cool so when it comes to comparing these
two implementations they're actually
equivalent in terms of their time and
space complexity right all right
programmers that's all i got for this
javascript walkthrough i want you to
practice uh both the iterative and
recursive versions because they're gonna
both be a very useful for the next
upcoming problems i'll see you there
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over an approach we can use
for this sum list problem
so in this problem we're going to be
given a singly linked list containing
numbers as the values what you want to
do is return the total sum of all the
values in the linked list so for this
particular input we should return a
total sum of 20.
and so how can we go about solving this
really just reviewing a core linked list
pattern right all you have to do here is
just traverse an order through the
linked list and you can accumulate a sum
so let's say we start from the beginning
if we initialize some sum variable to 0
we can also just use a pointer that
starts at the head of our linked list
and what we can do is we can take
current value and add it into our sum
just updating the sum so i take my
current value of 2 add it to my sum my
total sum is right now 2. then i can set
current equal to current next
i can add this 8 into my sum getting 10
next iteration i can add my 3 into the
sum getting 13. next iteration i can add
7 into the sum getting 20. right and i
know that technically 7 does have a next
pointer and it does point to null so
let's say i drew that out explicitly
what i can do at this point is actually
continue my algorithm
and i can make the stopping condition
when my current points to null right so
in general we can code this up by saying
a loop like you know while current is
not null if we talk about the complexity
of this algorithm it's pretty
straightforward we're technically just
iterating through every node so if n is
the number of nodes we have o of n time
roughly one iteration of for every node
and then our space complexity here is
actually o of one if we do this
iteratively right the only variables we
need to maintain are really just current
and also the sum variable and we're just
going to store some primitive values in
there so we have a nice constant space
solution over here
so the aerative is really
straightforward
just for you know complete understanding
how can we solve this one recursively
well if you solve it recursively that
means you have to you know call your
function many times and we start with a
top level call on the headnote of two
and what this should do is really just
call upon the next node right so i could
should call upon head.next so that
should give me a call to this eight node
and that should call upon the three node
and that should call upon the seventh
node and finally the seventh node should
actually call upon its next which would
be the null node
and that will actually act as my base
case i think it's a really great one
what i can do with this base case right
if my node is null
then i can just return zero right think
of null as if it's an empty linked list
what is the total sum of an empty list
well that would definitely be 0. so i'm
going to plug in this return value right
so i'm saying this call to the null node
is going to return 0.
when we say return that means return to
your caller so this zero would actually
be returned into the seven node
what the seven node should do is add its
current value right its own value into
that number
giving seven and then that returns up
the stack at this point i return back to
the 3 node 3 can add its value with that
7 giving 10 and just returning that up
8 can do the same giving me 18.
and finally 2 can add itself into that
return value giving us 20. and that
would be the correct answer right so
there are plenty of ways to implement
this one if we solve it recursively
we're definitely going to have one call
for every node within our linked list so
that would be o of n time and the space
complexity would actually be a little
more than our iterative
we would have o of n space here because
of the call stack right typically when
we analyze our recursive functions we
should include the space utilized for
making these recursive function calls
right so o of n over here
and notice that when we bottom out at
our base case we would have you know
roughly like four or five things on the
call stack all right so those are the
two strategies i think will code up and
i'll catch you in the walk through video
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this sum list problem
so i think we'll get things kicked off
by implementing a iterative version for
this
so i know i want to create a sum and add
to it over time so i'll create that
variable i'll say let sum equal zero i
know by the end of this function i'm
just going to return
that total sum
now i need to lay down my very you know
standard code for just traversing
through a link list so i'll say let
current i'm going to keep updating this
variable over time and it's going to
initialize with
simply the head node
and i know that in the loop for this
kind of classic linked list traversal i
just want to iterate while current is
not equal to null right if it's not
equal to null then it's a node so i can
actually look to its next pointer
so i know i'm going to need this pattern
right set current equal to current
dot next this actually steps through you
know the linked list in sequence but how
do i actually want to utilize my current
node's value well i just want to take it
and add it into the sum right so sum
plus equals
current dot val and eventually once i
hit the very very end of the linked list
i know current is going to be equal to
null so i exit the while loop and i'll
just return my total sum
so let's run this
just a little variation off of our last
problem just doing some computation
along the way
nice and now i think i'll show you the
recursive version which i quite like
so for your recursive version it's all
about starting with a meaningful base
case right so first thing you think
about is all right typically for my
linked list problems my base case is
about my head being null right and that
kind of represents the scenario where my
linked list is an empty linked list
right if it's null it means it has no
nodes so what's the total sum of an
empty linked list well it's just zero so
i'll check if head is equal to null
then just return zero
it's important i think about compatible
types here i know
when my linked list actually contains
some nodes then i should return a number
and even in the base case i should
return a number it's just the case that
i returned the number zero
nice let's say now we write our
recursive code right if the head is not
null then it's actually a node so i can
look at its value right it's a head dot
val
what i want to do is take that number
and add it to the sum of the remaining
nodes in the linked list how can i get
the sum of the remaining nodes after my
current position well that's just about
calling your function recursively right
and passing along dot next right
so always try to think about your
recursive call for the type of data that
it returns right it gives me back a
number representing the total sum of
everything starting at the next node
i'll take that number add it to my value
that should give me my complete sum so
i'll just return it
so i'll give this a shot
and the recursive code is quite short
one thing we should consider though when
it comes to like an apple staples
comparison between the recursive and the
iterative
they both have the same runtime right
they both have o n in the case of my
recursion i have n calls in the case of
my iterative code i have and just
iterations in the while loop
but the recursive version also uses n
space right that's because for recursion
we actually have to add
every function call onto the call stack
so i know by the time
that my recursion bottoms out at a base
case i would have n calls on the call
stack whereas in the case of our
iterative code we would actually use
only a constant amount of space because
they only use a handful of variables
here that being said i highly recommend
that you practice both of these
solutions because depending on the
problems that we solve you may find a
one more natural to use than the other
hey programmers before we continue the
course on linkedlist i just want to make
you all aware of my own data structure
and algorithm platform that is
structee.net if you haven't noticed
already all the content that you're
watching in this course as well as some
of my other material on free codecamp is
also
on structure.net with a lot of other
topics covered as well so if you go into
the course i cover all those classic you
know data structure algorithm topics
with tons of videos for every single one
so if you like my teaching style i think
you'll also enjoy structure.net and if
you hop into any particular problem i'll
give you a quick little tour over here
so if we go to this insert node problem
like you expect you can write your code
you can view the problem you can run
your code see the output but i think
most importantly what will bring you the
most value is
my kind of signature of videos right so
you're going to be able to have a high
level approach for every single problem
as well as the code walkthroughs you get
the nuts and bolts code implementation
for every single problem and even still
if you're not like a javascript i know
that this free codecamp video is in
javascript you can totally switch the
language so for all of my c plus plus
people in the crowd
doing so that is switching to c plus
plus would obviously change the prompt
in the text editor but also you'd get
different videos right here you see
a c plus specific video over here right
so if you've been enjoying my content
and just want to check out more a data
structure algorithm material with me
head over to structure.net i'll leave a
link to the platform in the youtube
video description and with that let's
head back into our linked list course
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over the approach we can use
for this linked list find problem and
i'll show you two ways to solve this one
so in this problem we're going to be
taking in a linked list as input and we
also have a target value we want to do
is return true or false whether or not
the target value is contained within the
linked list so for this particular
example if i'm asking for a target of c
you should return true because c is
definitely within the linked list in
another scenario let's say i gave you a
target of g and that's an area you would
just return false because g is not a
value of this linked list
to solve this one we're just going to
use our classic linked list traversal
algorithm so we'll step through it as if
we're looking for c so in the long run
we expect to give back a true here
well i know that they're going to give
me the head of the linked list as input
and i'll create a current variable that
points to the head node of course i'm
going to progressively update this
current variable to be the next node
over time right so what i can do is
whenever i'm situated at some current
node i can check if my current value is
equal to my target value so right now i
would check is a equal to c it's not and
so i should keep looking through the
linked list i know that current also has
a next property so i'll update current
to be current.next and then i check is b
equal to c it's not so i keep going
and finally i can hit a point where i
see that my current value of c is equal
to my target value of c and so i can
just do an early return true right once
i find a match within my linked list i
can just return my final answer
now let's say we had the opposite
scenario let's say that my target was g
we're going to start the algorithm in
the same way we start at current and we
keep looking through the linked list
and we set current equal to current next
eventually we know that current is going
to be equal to null which sort of
signifies that we've hit the very end of
our linked list all right and at this
point once we finish iterating through
the entire linked list we know that we
didn't see the target value because we
were checking the entire way through and
so at this point we can do return false
this is a really practical programming
pattern right where we check some
conditional inside of a loop and if we
find something we're looking for we'll
return true early then afterwards after
our loop's done running we'll return
false late
we talk about this iterative strategy we
know that if n is the number of nodes
we're just going to iterate through
every node of the link list so we would
have a runtime of o of n and our space
complexity here would just be o of one
because we're just using a constant
number of variables
so that was the iterative solution how
can you also solve this one recursively
so let's say we were looking for the
target of c and we had a more recursive
point of view so we know we're going to
make a top level call on the head node
of our link list
and i can just think about some base
cases to use here right and i know i
need two base cases right one that can
return true and another that can return
false so for my first base case i can
just simply check all right if my head's
value is equal to my target then just
return true
and the opposite scenario let's say that
my head is null then i should just
return false what i always try to do
with my recursive code is to think about
my base cases as if they're their own
valid inputs so in particular for base
case number two
if head is null then that kind of
represents uh the empty linked list
if my link list is empty then i can
return false because i definitely can't
find the target within an empty linked
list
so how would this run for our current
input of target c
well i would check all right is a
my target it's not so i make a recursive
call upon b
same thing right it's not make another
call upon c and at this point i see that
my current head's value is equal to my
target and so this node's going to
return the boolean true and i know that
this return value is going to return
back to its color of b
and then b is going to pass it back up
to a and of course a returns it to the
very very top level call
let's say we had a scenario where our
target was not found within the linked
list like g then we can see the other
base case fire at the very end right so
i know i'm going to make a call on a
a calls b
b calls c i still don't find the value
c calls d and finally when d looks at
its next it's gonna pass along null
right because d's next is technically
null and at this point i have just hit
base case number two so i can return
false and like before i return these
values
up the call stack
when we talk about the complexity of
this recursive algorithm we can say that
n is the number of nodes we're
definitely going to have o of n runtime
because we make a call for every node of
the linked list but we also have of n
space right because each of those calls
by the time we bottom out at a base case
we would have to store those on the call
stack we know that the worst case
scenario is
if our target is not found within the
linked list
that being said i think these are two
fair algorithms to go ahead and
implement so give it a shot on your own
if you get stuck i'll catch you in the
walkthrough videos see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this linked list find problem
so i'll jump right in and i'll start by
showing y'all the iterative solution and
so we'll start with our pointer variable
we'll say let current equal the head
and we'll just lay down the foundation
right we know we always need to iterate
while current is not equal to null
and while it's not null if we want to
progress to the next node of the linked
list just set current equal to current
dot next
now i just need to work in the logic
specific to this problem right as i
check every current node i want to see
if it's value so if current.val if that
is equal to my target and if it's equal
to my target then i can just return true
because i found the thing i'm looking
for
what i want to do is return false only
after the while loop right
it's important that i return false after
the while loop because only after you
check every single node of the linked
list can you actually confirm that hey
the target value is not within the
linked list what you don't want to do
is write a like if
return true and then else return false
right this code would be wrong
because let's say you don't find the
target value in the very first node of
the linked list then you would just
incorrectly return false without even
looking at the rest of the link list
so none of that you at least want your
code like this
so let's give it a test run see what we
get nice and there we have our iterative
solution for this linkless find problem
let me quickly show you the recursive
version of this it's going to be very
similar
so in the approach video if you haven't
watched the approach video recommend you
do but in the approach video we
mentioned that we can solve this
recursively by just using two base cases
right
i'll start with the base case if my head
is equal to null right so that kind of
represents the end of my linked list or
also just the empty linked list so if
head is null i can't possibly find the
target within an empty linked list so
just return false
now i need my other base case right i
need my like affirmative base case
so if head is not null then i can look
inside of head and i can check if head
dot val is equal to my target and i've
just found the thing i'm looking for so
just return true so two base cases here
right one affirmative and then one that
returns false
but let's say neither of these are true
right so my head is not null
and my head value is not equal to my
target well then i need to check the
rest of the linked list so here's where
i bring in recursion and i check the
next note so link list fine of head.next
and you can pass along the same exact
target so this is going to tell me all
right is the target found in the next
note of the linked list or in the
remainder of the linked list and i know
that this call is going to return a
boolean piece of data right either true
or false i just want to pass that up
so this should be good to go pretty
concise
code
give that a shot cool and there we have
a solution that's recursive for this
problem
do bear in mind when it comes to the
comparison of the complexities
technically we would prefer the
iterative version right they both have
linear time but the iterative version
has constant space right because i'm
just using like a current variable
whereas my recursive code uses a linear
amount of space because of the call
stack
that being said what i want you to do is
practice both of these solutions and
i'll catch you in the next problem
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over the approach we can use
for this get node value problem
so in this problem we're going to take
in a linked list and what we want to do
is also accept an index as input what we
want to do is really return the node's
value at that given index and we will
start counting our indices at zero in
other words we'll consider the head of
our linked list as having index zero so
for this particular example if i asked
you for index two of this linked list
you should return the value of the c
node right so just return the value c
and of course i could be giving you any
particular index as input
so what this question asks is pretty
straightforward but how can we go about
solving this one so what we can do here
is a basic counting algorithm so we know
we want to return the node's value who
has index two so when we initialize our
current pointer to be the head of the
linked list we'll initialize our count
to zero then from here it's just our
classic logic right i know i can set
current equal to current.next and when i
do that i'll also increment my count so
now count is 1. basically i have tracked
the index of my current node that i'm
iterating through
next iteration when current goes to c
and of course i increment my count to
two at this point i can see that my
target index and my count are equal and
so i can just return the value within
that particular node
but i think about this strategy it's
pretty straightforward in that if n is
the number of nodes the time complexity
is simply o of n right because in the
worst case we just have to traverse
through the entire linked list
we can also see that the space
complexity for this is constant because
we're just tracking some simple number
variables
so that's how you can solve this one
iteratively how can you also think of
this one recursively though
so let's reframe our point of view here
let's say that we were forced to solve
this one recursively and we know we
still want to find the value at index
two and when i make a call i know that
the top level caller is going to pass
along the head of the linked list so the
a node and also their target index of
two
i can use my classic recursive a linked
list traversal algorithm so i make a
recursive call on my next node when i
make the recursive call on the next node
what i should also do is pass along the
index but decrease it by one
so now i'm able to see that hey this
current node of b
has index one
and if i keep doing this next iteration
i call upon my next node of c
and i also decrement my index down to
zero
once my index is at zero that basically
means that i want to return this very
node right so if index is equal to zero
we'll return node.value that would be
our base case
and once we return that value i know
that i'm going to return back up the
stack so the c value returns to its
caller
and so on and so forth
very classic a recursive code
so this looks like a nice recursive
algorithm we analyze the complexity of
this we're going to see that the time
complexity is still linear and the space
complexity is actually also linear here
here we incur a little more space
complexity because we're going to be
storing every call upon the call stack
so what i want you to do is on your own
try to give it a shot and implement both
the recursive and iterative solutions
for this problem and if you get stuck
i'll catch you in the walkthrough videos
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
you can use for this get node value
problem so hopefully you already watched
the approach video if not highly
recommend you do that and we'll start by
implementing maybe that recursive
strategy off the bat
so i'm going to need two base cases here
like we said in the approach and one of
them typically is always going to be if
our head is equal to null that means
i've hit the end of my linked list or i
have an empty linked list and what i
should do is just return
null
that will actually cover a few scenarios
if i look at the examples here
sometimes we may actually get past a
very very large index so notice here
they're asking for the value at index 7
but the linked list only has
four
different nodes that means the index of
the last node d would be three right
zero one two three so if ever our target
index is out of range then we should
just return null
and so this should help me satisfy that
because i'm going to return null once i
fall off the edge of the linked list
nice
we're going to need another base case
what if we actually find the particular
node that we need to return its value
for
so i know over time i'm going to
decrement my index like we said in the
approach
so i can check if my index is equal to
zero then simply return
this current node the current node would
be head
dot val right returning its value
nice so bear in mind we're counting down
here and so in my recursive code i need
to call my function get node value
pass along the next node
of the linked list and then pass along
index minus one
and i know that this call is going to
return the value of the node at the
given index so i should just return
whatever that comes back as
if i do a quick sanity check here bear
in mind we're counting downwards so for
like this example example 0 0 we know
that a is going to have an index of 2
right technically because we're going
downward and when i make the call for b
it's going to receive index 1. when i
call on c c is going to receive index 0
which means i should just return that
back up the stack
so kind of counting downwards here in
the reverse
but this should be a nice solution let's
give this a test run
bear in mind that the solution has a
linear type complexity and also a linear
space complexity
we can actually cut down on the space if
we write the iterative version so i'll
show you that right now
so the iterative translation you should
be very familiar with probably wondering
why are we doing such simple problems
well it's about to get more difficult
right to me it's all about the
foundations so our classic strategy is
for iterations set your current variable
to be the head node right and i'll just
lay out the classic traversal so while
my current
is not equal to null then keep on going
to progress to the next node in the
sequence what i should do is set current
equal to current dot next
and now i need to work in the
problem-specific logic here right
i know i want to return the node at the
given index and for these iterative
patterns i'll count upwards so i'll set
some count variable equal to 0
just like this
and whenever i progress to the next node
of the linked list
i'll set count plus equals one so i'm
counting upward
so when i get to some point when my
count
is equal
to my target index then i can just
return
this node right so i can return
this node's value so again we're
counting upward in the error diversion
whereas in the recursive version we
counted downward
nice
let's go ahead and run this code there's
one thing that probably won't pass but
we'll give it a go
see what happens
so i'm getting a little error here get
node value has already been declared
because of course i have it defined
twice
so we'll try that again can't redeclare
your const variables
so i'll run it
and we're failing test zero two which is
the test where our index or our target
index is too large so here's zero two
so we should have our function return
null if we can't find the node at the
specified index right now we're
returning undefined
which is happening because
this while loop is actually ending right
we're going to hit the very very tail of
our linked list and so our y loops over
and we're just going to hit line 16.
when we fall off the edge of our
function evaluation we're just going to
by default return undefined so to fix
this it's quite straightforward just by
default return null
and that should satisfy that scenario
let's give it a run there
cool and there we have an iterative
solution
so for this iterative solution it has a
linear time complexity just like the
recursion but it has a better space
complexity right here we consider this
constant space because we only use a
handful of variables like current and
count that being said what i want you to
do is practice both of these
implementations because in the next few
problems it's going to get a little more
involved i'll see you there
hey programmers welcome back right now
let's go over an approach we can use for
this reverse list problem
so in this problem we're going to take
in a linked list as input what we want
to do here is actually reverse the order
of the nodes in this linked list so if
our input list contains the values a b c
d
in place meaning we want to mutate now
the existing linked list in place we
want to actually change the order to
dcba just ending up with the linked list
in reverse order
in this function what we should do is
also return the new head of the linked
list so technically your function for
this input should return the d node so
let's come up with a strategy we can use
to solve this one
when it comes to the tools we can use
for a linked list we know more or less
we always have to iterate or traverse
through the entire linked list and we
know that that requires at least one
pointer typically we call it current
the trick here is to actually use
multiple variables
so let's say i began my classic current
pointer pointing at the head of the
linked list
what i'll also need is to track the
previous note i've visited at the start
because i haven't visited any other
nodes we can make this previous pointer
point to null
and we know this entire time if i have
access to current i also have access to
the next node in the list right by just
accessing
current.next
we're just going to label that as a
temporary variable here we'll call it
next and you'll see why in a little bit
so i know i need to have the long-term
effect of just reversing all of the next
pointers in this linked list in other
words i need to make a point to null and
so what i can do is literally just set
current.next in other words setting the
arrow to point to previous ending up
with this
now it should be abundantly clear why we
save the b node with that next variable
because once we reroute currents.next to
point to null we would lose access if we
didn't have that next variable
so what i can do now is shift my point
of view i can set my current to be the
next and set my previous to be the old
current just shifting my point of view
like this and now i can set current.next
to be the previous node once again
rerouting this pointer and this process
continues
as we get toward the end of the linked
list what we have to also remember is
technically since d
is the old tail of the linked list this
entire time it actually did have a next
pointer it just happened to point to
null
and so at this point i can actually
continue my general algorithm right i
still set
current.next to my previous rerouting
this pointer and i can actually continue
one more iteration if i set current to
be the next it's now the case that
current is actually at null which means
we hit the end of our linked list and we
can stop our algorithm if we look at the
current state of our linked list it is
in reverse order right d points to c
points to b points to a points to null
so things are good to go there and if i
wanted to return the new head of the
linked list i can simply return
the final value of the previous variable
so that actually works out pretty
elegant
if we do the analysis for this algorithm
if we implement this in an iterative way
and we say n is the number of nodes we
know that the runtime is just going to
be o of n really just traversing through
the entire linked list once we can see
that space complexity is constant
because we only need a fixed number of
variables so overall this is a maximum
efficient algorithm to reverse a linked
list
when we go on to the code walkthrough
for this i'll actually show you how to
implement this iteratively and
recursively uh bearing in mind that the
recursive would actually suffer a
slightly worse space complexity but
before we get there try to give this a
shot on your own implement this and if
you get stuck i'll catch you in the
walkthrough video see you there
hey programmers welcome back right now i
want to go over a javascript solution we
can use for this reverse list problem so
hopefully you already watched the
approach video if not i highly recommend
it because we're going to implement that
strategy pretty closely
so i'll start with the iterative version
here and we know we just need to lay
down at least initially our classic
linked list traversal so i'm just going
to keep my current variable initialize
that to head and loop while my current
is not equal to null
and i know that the basic code would
always be set currents equal to
current.next that would just move
sequentially through the linked list but
now we need to work in a few other
variables right
so the key here is to have some variable
we'll call it previous and to initialize
it equal to null
and if we're wondering why null is a
great default value for this previous
just think about what needs to happen on
the very very first iteration of our
while loop so we know that our current
is going to be a
and in the long run we know a's next
needs to actually point to null right
because it needs to become the tail so
if we initialize previous with null on
the first iteration we can immediately
just say current.next
equals previous right that would
actually
have that arrow point to null which is
good to go
but then at this point we need to make
sure that we have some proper references
here
so before we just reassign current.next
if we just overwrote it willy-nilly then
we would lose access to whatever the
actual next note sequentially was so
i'll save that to a variable i'll say
maybe const next equals current.next
and then after i overwrite it i can
still make progress to the next node of
the linked list by simply setting
current equal to next
awesome
so that's looking pretty good
and not only do i need to progress
current but previous should now also
point to current shifting my full
point of view
so some pretty tricky logic over here
let's go ahead and maybe analyze a
little bit closer what it's doing
so leave some ascii art here
so let's say we had a linked list that
looked like this so a points to b
points to c
we know we have initially
current over here right so current is
pointing to a we know that when i save
that next variable it's going to point
to this b over here so i'll save that
and technically at the very start we
initialized previous to be null so i'll
just use like capital n to represent
null
and i know previous is going to point to
that like this
awesome
so on the first iteration we have all
these variables set up and i set
current.next equal to previous
current.next is represented by this
arrow so when i set current.next to be
previous it has this
visual
representation right just setting it the
opposite direction once i do that would
actually lose this arrow
and now you can probably see why we
saved next for b right that way i don't
lose access to the rest of the linked
list
cool at this point i can set some
variables right i can make previous
the current so i'll set it like this
then i also set current to the next so
basically just shift over the point of
view
and if you look at the state of my
drawing now things are actually
perfectly aligned for the next iteration
i would just set current.x to be
previous once again
and so on and so forth all the way
through the very end of the linked list
and like we said in the approach uh once
we actually end when current is equal to
null you exit the while loop and
previous would actually contain the new
head of the linked list so i'm just
going to return
previous over here it does make sense
that previous would be the new head of
the linked list because after i exit the
y loop i know previous is going to be
the original tail right if i'm reversing
the tail becomes a head and vice versa
cool so really just a spin off of our
classic linked list traversal i will
tell you that the logic here can get
pretty tricky especially with these
temporary variables
so we'll give it a test run see what we
get
and hopefully we'll have this nice of n
runtime of one space solution
awesome there we have it
and so what i'll also do now is show you
the recursive version
it will have a slightly worse
space complexity although the code is
noticeably more concise so i think it's
still worth practicing
so really we're just going to translate
the same premise into its recursive
version right
so i'm going to still need like access
to two variables or two pointers
and the way i establish that recursively
is by using a default argument here so
i'll set previous equal to null
so if you're unfamiliar in javascript
this is how you just do a default
argument right so if someone does not
pass in a second argument when they call
reverse list by default it's going to be
set to null and i can start with a
classic base case right if head is null
then i've hit the end of my linked list
and what i can do is actually just
return previous for the same reason i
returned previous over here right
previous would actually be the new tail
and when it comes to actually writing
the recursive code i'm just going to try
my best to translate all of these
iterative patterns into their recursive
analogs
so i'm going to save a reference to
the head next just in a temporary
variable
because if i overwrite it by saying
head.next equals previous i would lose
access to it otherwise
so now i at least have a way to call
recursively and traverse through the
rest of the linked list so pass in next
as the new head
and pass in head
as the new previous really just shifting
that point of view once again
if i think about the return value for
reverse list i know it's going to return
a node right it's going to return
hopefully the new head of the linked
list so i just want to pass up that
return value do stay aware in this
problem they say your function should
return the new head
of the reverse link list and this should
actually satisfy that
so i'll give this a run
nice and here we have a o of n time
recursive solution that is also a o of n
space right so apple samples comparison
if you wanted to get the most efficiency
you should prefer the iterative version
that being said i still think there's a
nice value to practicing both of these
this is actually a pretty common uh
interview problem so make sure you have
this down pat before we hop into the
next problem i'll see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over the approach we can use
for the zipperless problem
so in this problem we're going to take
in two linked lists what i want to do is
zipper these two lists together in other
words i need to in place reassign all of
these next pointers such that we
alternate between the nodes of list one
and list two it also looks like we
should always start with the first node
of list one and then from that point on
simply alternate that being said let's
take a look at another example we don't
have many assumptions we can use when it
comes to the lengths of both of our
lists except that we know that each list
is actually not empty
but besides that what if one of my lists
was longer than the other well then what
i want to do is alternate as much as i
can and then just terminate the linked
list with the remaining nodes so notice
i alternate with aqbr at which point i
don't have any more nodes in list two so
i just take all the remaining nodes of
list one and add them to the very end
and so i want to keep that edge case in
mind when we come up with a strategy for
this one
so where do we even start with a problem
like this
well you should be familiar with our
core linked list pattern right we just
know how to traverse sequentially
through a linked list and so what i can
do is actually maintain two pointers at
a time right one for list one and
another for list two so let's say we
started stepping through this example i
know i'm past both of these head nodes
head 1 and head 2 respectively and then
from there i can set up some respective
current pointers and so given in the
examples we always want to start with
the head node of list one so i'm just
going to start that down here
and what i'll need to do is also track
the tail
of my output list right although we're
just reassigning
all of our pointers in place we're going
to need a reference that way we can
figure out how we can add new nodes to
our current output we'll say
and since i already begin my chain with
the first node of list one then i need
to be sure that i actually progress
current one and so current one should
really be pointing at this b node
and so now that i have at least a
starting node how can i come up with a
general algorithm here well if you want
to establish a simple alternating
pattern then what you can do is just use
a counter variable have it start at zero
and then based on whether or not the
count is even or odd that would tell you
from which list you should take your
next node and so since i already began
with a node from list one what i should
do is whenever my count is even i'm
going to grab a node from list two when
count is odd i'm going to grab a node
from list one so right now count to zero
zero is technically an even number and
so i'm going to take my next node from
list two
so i look at my current two pointer and
it tells me i should just take
that q node and add it as the next of my
tail and so now that i've consumed a
node from list two i need to be sure i
progress current two to its next just
like this
i also need to make progress on some
other pointers here i need to progress
my tail also to its next that way i can
get set up for the next iteration of the
algorithm
at this point i need to increment my
count by one so now count is one since
my count is odd i should take a node
from list one so i look at my current
one pointer and i add b to the tail just
like this
and i make progress on all of my
variables right so i'm going to progress
current 1 i'm going to progress my tail
and increment my count to 2.
since it's even now i should take a node
from list2 so i take my r from current2
and when i set current two to its next
it's going to become null when i set
tail to its next it's going to be set to
the r
and then i increment my count so now my
count is three
and now i have an important scenario it
looks like i've exhausted all of the
nodes in list two
we spoke about this scenario right
whenever we finish all of the nodes of
one of our lists we should just
terminate our output with all the
remaining nodes of our other list the
non-empty list
and so at this point
what i can do is just take my current
one basically this c chain and
everything after it
and just put it after the tail in my
output
just like this and of course i want to
complete the connection
over here
and this would actually be the correct
output and so overall our strategy was
to maintain pointers to both of our
respective linked lists and maintain a
count right depending on whether the
count is even or odd then that'll tell
me from which list i should take my next
node and along with that we also need to
maintain some tail points that we can
use so we can actually build up the link
list output
let's talk about the complexity of this
one
since we have two linked lists as input
into this problem we should probably use
two terms to describe its complexity so
if i say n is the length of list one and
i say m is the length of list two then i
can say the time complexity is the
minimum between n and m
recall that when we just stepped through
this algorithm we really only needed as
many iterations as the shorter linked
list recall the algorithm we just traced
through now once we hit the end of one
of our linked lists
we know we just finished the algorithm
by taking the remaining nodes of the
other list and just tack it on to the
end and that finishing step only takes a
of one time so really as soon as one of
our linked lists runs out which will
always be in general the shorter one
then i can just finish my algorithm i
actually don't have to iterate fully
through both of them
and i would still consider this
technically you know some form of a
linear runtime
for the space complexity we can see that
the space here is just constant right
we're not actually creating any new
nodes we're simply rerouting all of
these next pointers
and in terms of our variables we only
use a fixed number of them and so
overall this seems like a reasonable
strategy what i want you to do is try to
code up this one on your own it's going
to be some really interesting code a new
pattern for us that is and if you get
stuck i'll catch you in the walkthrough
videos see you there
hey programmers alvin here right now i
want to go over a javascript solution
for this zipperless problem
so we'll jump right in hopefully watch
the approach video and we'll start with
an iterative version of this the way
we're going to attack this one is by
doing our classic linked list traversal
but do it twice over for a head 1 and
head to simultaneously really
so i'll set my let current one
start at head one and i'll also set let
current two to start at head two
and i'm going to need my main loop just
to iterate through now the linked list
so i can check
while current one is not null
and
current two
is not null so notice as soon as one of
my linked lists hits its end this loop
would actually stop right
cool
what we want to be sure to do is set up
also a way to create the output so if
you look at the prompt
we always start with
the first node of list one so in this
particular example i'm zippering abc and
xyz i always start with the a here
and i'm gonna use that to get the ball
rolling on my resulting list we're not
gonna create any new nodes but we do
have to rewire all of these next
pointers
so what i'll say is maybe let's
we'll say head over here and this will
be the head of our output because i know
i need to return that by the end
something like that i'm going to start
head
really as
head one
technically
and then current one will actually have
to start one after that like we said in
the approach so i'll set current one
equal to
we'll say
head dot next
that'll be a good uh starting point from
there
and in addition to having this a head
pointer that's because i want to return
you know the new head of the linked list
which i guess would be the same as head
one now that i think of it so maybe we
don't need this variable
but we do need is a pointer that we can
append after right so i'm going to say
let tail i think as a matter of fact i'm
going to set tail equal
to
head 1.
so i know head 1 is going to be the
first note in my output and over time i
need to add things after the tail
building up my resulting list
so that's looking pretty good
now we'll go ahead and increment our
counter or add that into the mix here so
we'll say
let
count
begin it at zero
and depending on whether or not our
count is even or odd that can tell me
whether i should take a node from list
one or list two
so i think we're ready to hop into our
main code over here i know i should end
any particular iteration by of course
incrementing the count right count plus
equals one i'm just going to put that
down there so i don't forget
and i will start by checking the parity
of that count right whether or not it's
even or odd so i'll simply check if
count mod
2
is equal to zero all right so that means
it's even then else it's odd so bear in
mind i started my output list with a
node from
head one from list one
and initially i start my count equal to
zero so i guess when my count is zero
i'll take something from list two
so what i can do is take whatever
current two it's pointing at so current
two
and i want to make that the next
of the tail
right tail is helping me build the
output so simply tail dot next equals
current two
nice then from there since i just used
up something from list2 i need to
progress that so current2 equals
current2.next
and i know that this code over here when
it's odd it's going to be symmetric just
for current one
[Music]
and in addition to that we need to make
sure that we also move our tail pointer
that's going to happen in either
scenario so i can put that mutual code
over here i think i'll say tail equal
tail dot next
nice so this should help me construct
my alternating pattern
but we have to worry about is based on
my while loop this while loop is going
to terminate or end as soon as one of my
current pointers
hits null and it could be the case that
only one of them is null and the other
one is still pointing to some data and
like we said in the approach what we
should do is just tack on all of the
nodes of the other list to our final
output here
so what i'll do is i'll check all right
if let's say
current one
if it still has stuff so it's not equal
to null then i can just
take that stuff and add it to the tail
so
tail dot next equals
current one
and
symmetric for current two of course
so if i look at the prompt over here
we're thinking about a scenario like
this one right here we know that current
one is way longer now than current two
or list one is longer than list two
and so by the time we get to the end of
list two we know that roughly we're
going to be at about this c note or this
d node in list one we just want to take
all those remaining elements looks like
d
and add it to the end of that list
notice i just end in d e f
cool and we just need to check both
sides of that also i think at this point
let's give this a nice test run i'm
gonna always debug it together
it's not too long of some code but it
does have some interesting patterns
awesome here we have a nice iterative
solution for zipperless for this code
we're looking at a linear runtime and
constant space
and so
i think what we'll do is let me also
show you how you could solve this one
recursively
it's
very similar in strategy so much shorter
code and i'll leave it to you whether or
not you think it's more simple or not
we will have to concede though that for
any recursive code especially for this
one we're going to have some additional
stack space used so we would have a
linear space for recursion as well so
i'm going to do my best to translate
these patterns so i know i should stop
my recursion we'll say if head 1
is null
and head 2 is null
[Music]
so that's very similar to what we just
said in our iterative version
and if they're null then you kind of at
the end you can just return
null
what i have to be sure i do is
for my function it needs to return like
the new head of the linked list and so
i'll just have some base case here where
i return null
because basically a linked list contains
like many sub lists right what you
should be doing as you solve
linked list problems recursively is
if you think of let's say
this as a link list going from a through
z then going from x to z is also a
linked list going from b to z is also a
linked list
so that's how i kind of break down my
problem size
so if they're both null then return null
but what if only one of them is null
right so what if head one
is null
all right and that would mean if head
one is the only one that's known that
means head two has some stuff well then
just return the remainder of head two
and make that symmetric for
the other side right so if head 2 is
null and head 1 isn't then just return
the remainder of head 1. and what this
base case or these base cases will let
me do
is accomplish some logic
just like this right how can i take all
of the leftover nodes in the case of one
of my lists running out and just tack it
on to the end right if one of my
pointers runs out i'm just going to
return the other pointer
cool which would be the leftover chain
now i need my
recursive code
so there are a few ways you can write
this
instead of using the modulo trick and
checking for even or odd what i should
be able to do is take two nodes at a
time here so let's say i know i need to
make my head
head 1 really so i'm going to return
head 1 i think at the end
and i need to make
head 1 dot next
point to whatever head two is
right
and as soon as i do that i would
actually lose access to the original
head one next so i should have saved
that so i'll say
maybe const next one equals head one dot
next before i overwrite it and i guess
why not while we're here we'll also do
the same for next two pretty common
thing we have to do for our linked list
problems right before you overwrite a
pointer maybe save it in case you need
it still
so i'm making head one next point to
head to
and then from there i know i need to
call recursively zipper list on
next one
and also
next two it should be
right
and then from here i just chained head
one to add 2 i know zipperless is going
to return the head of the remaining
linked list i just need to chain that
to head 2 so i had 2.next equals that
return value because again i'm going to
return a node from this recursive call
so this code is looking pretty good
let's go ahead and test it
it is quite a bit shorter
so we're getting error zipper list is
not defined
because i need s here that's on me
let's give that a go again
a little typo there
nice and here we have a nice recursive
solution for this
and so just to make sure we're on the
same page here maybe it's worth stepping
through at least one iteration together
and so let's say i had these let's add
abc and xyz
trace through at least one stack frame
of this so abc
and then x
y
z all right so i know in the context of
my
pointers i have h1 over here
right that's going to be head one
i also have head two of course so h2
over here
and what i do is i'm not hitting the
base cases for this because i have two
nodes and so we save some pointers to
their necks so nothing fancy here i have
next one over here
i have
next two over here
and in the core logic of actually
alternating what i do is i take head
ones dot next and point it to head two
so i don't wanna just kind of merge them
together in line over here so kind of
separately although you know i'm not
creating new nodes it would look like
this head one is a i said it's next to x
so that already looks good to go and
then from there i set head twos next
to whatever the recursive call is
when i pass along next one next two so
at this point i can kind of ignore these
right
so i'll take out
just this a node
and now h1
or head 1 points to b and the same thing
over here
h2 points to y and let's say we step
through this iteration well same thing i
just take head 1 and i know i'm going to
return head 1
right so eventually it's going to return
over here it's going to say b
points to y
right
because head one is b h2 is y head one
dot next equals head two
and that's good to go